Doctor Strange is a master class in visual
effects and taps into a whole new dimension—several
of them, actually—for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to explore.
But with so many elements in play, from time
manipulation to the multiverse to metaphysics
and even magic flying cloaks, there was so
much to explain that there were bound to be
a few loose ends left straggling.
Here are some of the major questions Doctor
Strange left unanswered.
"You're a man looking at the world through
a keyhole."
Fair warning: This video is filled with spoilers,
so those who haven't seen the movie yet should
hang out in another dimension for the time
being.
Why Earth?
As with many of Marvel's movie properties,
our mega-villain of the day, Dormammu, is
a creature that defies all logic.
He — or should we say it — is a being
existing outside time and space that likes
to feed on the many "generous" parts of the
universe that give life... and he's set a
giant purple eye on Earth.
Of all planets, why does our blue-green blob
become such an important conquest for Dormammu?
Our best guess is it wouldn't be a movie if
not — that's why.
How Ancient?
Doctor Strange asks the question we're all
wondering about—exactly how ancient is the
Ancient One?
We never find out.
Mordo does spill some vague details about
how she's of Celtic descent but nobody knows
anything more than that.
We can only imagine how she became this bald,
scarred, sophisticated wizard, and certainly
have no idea why she'd stick around Earth
if she had unlimited access to the entire
continuum of existence.
Why Mordo?
Mordo came to the Ancient One with an injury
of his own, but we don't know any details.
More importantly, it isn't clear why he was
ever chosen to be the Ancient One's apparent
second in command.
She certainly doesn't inspire confidence when
she tells Strange that she thinks Mordo has
an inflexible soul and can only conjure up
"he's strong" as a compliment for the character.
Why did she pluck him to be her right-hand
man if she thought he was so stiff?
Palmer who?
Obviously, Doctor Strange and Christine Palmer
have a history together, but we aren't getting
the whole story here.
On the one hand, he's quick to lash out at
her cruel words that demean their past romance.
On the other, he clings to a watch she gave
him with an inscription about their love standing
the test of time and turns to her multiple
times for help, so what gives?
What's the magic rule?
Those sorcerer protégés were pretty loose-lipped
about Kamar-Taj, weren't they?
Pangborn knew Strange for all of two minutes
before he let the source of his healing slip,
and Mordo was quick to guide him there, no
questions asked, when he heard him mutter
the name in passing.
It's all a matter of moving the plot along
in both cases, of course, but are there any
rules to when, how, or why you can just divulge
this information to strangers?
Seems like they might be a little more guarded
about their precious sanctuary is all we're
sayin'.
"Teach me"
Whose cloak?
We're told the Cloak of Levitation is a fickle
creature, but that's basically all we know
about it.
It's a compliment to Strange that the Cloak
has chosen him, but why?
What became of its last owner?
Did the Ancient One know this person?
Is it a sentient being?
The other magical artifacts we saw didn't
seem to have such strong personalities, so
what makes the Cloak so different?
No hands?
When Strange first joins the crew at Kamar-Taj,
he's not strong enough to heal his damaged
hands, but after he ascends to untold strength
and capability, he's still not able — or
perhaps not willing? — to undo the nerve
damage to his hands.
Is it because the one-handed master showed
off his fire-spinning skills and changed his
mind?
Or is he just incapable of willing his cells
and nerves to correct themselves?
Hard to say.
No mask?
Kaecilius and his cohorts all got some purple
skin masks, complete with scaly Stone Man
rot around their eyes, once they started channeling
dark power.
However, they only shared one facial tell
with the Ancient One, who'd done the same:
The insignia on their foreheads.
Why is it that she was immune to the Dormammu
mask, but not the symbol, when she was channeling
dark power?
Why wait?
It doesn't really make sense for the Ancient
One to die when she does.
Remember her big speech about how the body
has the ability to heal itself with the right
spiritual motivation?
No matter how grave her wounds might have
been during the battle with Kaecilius, she
should've been able to help herself.
Unless this was kind of an Obi-Wan Kenobi,
help Luke with the Force kinda thing…
But then, we've still got some other questions.
Doctor Strange definitely had the ability
to manipulate time by the point of her ultimate
injury, so why didn't he whip out his event
reversal trick to save her … or the London
Sanctum … or undo everything in New York,
for that matter?
"This doesn't make any sense."
"Not everything has to"
Okay.
No fair?
When Doctor Strange banishes Kaecilius and
his lackeys to Dormammu's dimension, they
float up and are instantly flayed alive—or
so it seems.
He says they're still getting their wish for
eternal life, but it isn't going to be pleasant.
What Strange experienced during his limited
time in Dormammu's dimension was an endless
barrage of brutality.
Are we to assume that's what's coming their
way, too?
They're obviously in the doghouse after picking
the fight that led Doctor Strange to Dormammu's
breakfast nook, but Kaecilius was clearly
a powerful sorcerer, so Dormammu will probably
keep him on his team, right?
Why Pangborn?
In the post-credits scene, Mordo has broken
bad after learning that the Ancient One had
been lying to him and drawing on dark energy.
Mordo's new mission is to trim down the list
of magicians around the world, and his first
victim of sorcery-stripping is Jonathan Pangborn.
This was a guy who had nothing to do with
any of this stuff and expressly chose not
to be a part of the Ancient One's army.
So why him?
Was Mordo getting vengeance for Pangborn sending
Strange to Kamar-Taj, or was the guy just
doing more than shooting hoops in his downtime?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos like
the one you just saw.
And don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love, too!